House Speaker Nancy Pelosi finally
agrees to hold a vote on the impeachment
inquiry at the behest of wait for it
Republicans we examine Pelosi
impeachment bind and the Democrats
biggest mistake they believe their own
press releases then a group of Indians
attacks black girls in New Jersey
because of white supremacy or something
according to the New York Times in the
dumbest article on the internet today
and finally more bad news for Joe Biden
as the nominally Catholic nominal
Democratic presidential frontrunner is
denied the Eucharist in a Catholic
Church
in South Carolina why well because he
supports killing babies that's no good
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the one thing we can say about the top
story in the bottom story today is at
least finally people are following their
ideas to their logical conclusions Nancy
Pelosi has been talking about the super
official formal totally serious
impeachment inquiry for weeks and weeks
now even though she's never held a vote
on the subject because nobody actually
wants the political accountability on
impeachment now we're gonna get that
same thing with the Catholic Church this
priest down in South Carolina should be
given a lot of plaudits because he is
following the ideas of the Catholic
Church to their logical conclusion and
saying if you support killing babies you
are not in communion with the church we
will examine what both of both of those
stories mean because the story for the
left and that's so great the story for
the Catholic Church and for the culture
pretty good news before we get to that I
have got to thank our friends over at
honey you know how much I love honey
because I've been using honey since long
before the daily wire even existed you
know what happens you go you buy
something online and you find out later
could be two hours later could be two
days later could be two weeks later that
you missed a discount I don't have to
overspend anymore thanks to honey it
honey is so good honey's the free
browser extension that saves you time
and money when shopping online it scans
the internet for coupon codes and other
discounts then like magic it
automatically applies the one with the
biggest savings to your cart at checkout
you might remember like from five six
years ago you would go online you'd want
to buy something in there there's a
little section for coupon codes and then
you scour the internet and you'd try to
get a coupon code and none of them would
work and you'd probably download seven
or twenty-five viruses that it was just
a mess you don't need to do that anymore
honey does all the work for you getting
you the absolute best deal it knows
about every coupon code sale or discount
at over 20,000 sites like Amazon Macy's
j.crew Domino's Sephora Target much much
more honey has found it's 10 million
users including me over a billion
dollars in savings you just go on you
shop like normal and honey working in
the background finds you the savings it
feels fabulous I use honey all the time
I don't remember even the last time I
used it I would be harder
remember the last time I didn't use
honey you go on there I mean even I saw
these one of these sunglasses there were
like three four hundred dollar
sunglasses honey just goes online
immediately saves me I don't think I
sold saved like 250 or 300 dollars it's
just fabulous fabulous browser extension
there is no reason not to use honey it's
free to use it installs on your computer
in two clicks get honey for free at join
honey dot-com slash cough fa Co V Fe Fe
oh that's a throwback huh jo Ann honey
dot-com / cough FA Co V Fe Fe is
absolutely fabulous and you will love it
so Nancy Pelosi had her bluff called on
impeachment and she is finally going to
take an actual vote put people on the
record on whether they want this
impeachment inquiry now she's not voting
on impeachment itself nobody would be
willing to do that right now but she is
willing to have a proper vote to
authorize impeachment why does this
matter because so far this impeachment
has been absolutely lawless in the
history of our country we impeached
President Johnson we then were about to
impeach Richard Nixon though he resigned
and we impeached Bill Clinton in all of
those cases when the impeachment inquiry
was taken up the house went on the
record and and had a formal vote on it
except this time why not this time
because this one is so obviously
ridiculous how do we know that this one
is ridiculous even without looking into
the details of the case of the phone
call to Ukraine we know it's ridiculous
because the Democrats have been trying
to impeach president Trump since before
he took office since right after the
election before Trump took office Senate
Democrats including Elizabeth Warren and
others tried to set the stages for
impeachment then after Trump took office
in 2017 representative Al Green the
congressman not the singer put forward a
resolution for impeachment that
resolution failed then they tried to
impeach him for Russian collusion that
was the premise of the Malheur
investigation then they threatened to
impeach him over stormy Daniels and
paying off a porn star now they're
trying to impeach him over colluding
with Ukraine the sworn enemy of Russia
if at first you
succeed try try again that alone shows
you how lawless the impeachment is so
Pelosi doesn't want to get people on the
record her constant want to go on the
record for this but Lindsey Graham
Republican and Trump ally in the Senate
very forcefully went on TV and said we
need to take a vote where this is
absolutely lawless and Pelosi eventually
agreed this is an unfair process being
driven by sore losers and there's not
one vote in the United States Senate to
impeach President Trump based on this
phone call because he did nothing wrong
in the history of the country we've
never had the Intelligence Committee
participate in an impeachment inquiry
under the resolution they're going to
pass tomorrow the president's counsel
cannot participate in the Intel
committee inquiry so the president's
denied right to counsel and Republicans
can't call witnesses without Schiff
agreeing so this whole thing is a sham
the backlash is going to be wide deep
because what they're doing in the
president Trump is unfair it's sore
losers can't accept the consequences of
losing an election and this process in
the house is a joke president Trump is
being treated unfairly and most
Americans are going to say so when they
understand what's happening so Lindsey
Graham has a lot of clarity on this he's
showing not just the irregularity of not
voting to initiate the impeachment
inquiry but all of the other
irregularities why does Adam Schiff get
to do whatever he wants why is the house
Intel Committee Chairman who has very
publicly lied before about this
president who has dealt in a very
improper way with the intelligence
community and with the media why is this
guy get to do anything and and the White
House has no right to fight back the the
president has no right to face his
accuser all of the so-called
whistleblowers are opaque we haven't
seen them even though the IG has
determined that the whistleblowers have
an anti-trump bias three different ways
it's judge so murky I think when most
Americans hear about this their eyes
glaze over they just don't understand
that they've their opinions have been
made on this months and months if not
years ago and so what Lindsey Graham is
trying to do is bring some clarity to
this bring it all out into the open not
just on the witnesses
not just on the investigation but the
premise of the investigation itself
who's calling for it and who is not so
he comes out there and he passed this
resolution he said Lindsey Graham calls
on the House of Representatives prior to
proceeding any further with with it's
impeachment investigation into President
Trump to vote to initiate a formal
impeachment inquiry Collison has
representatives to provide president
Trump like every other American with due
process to include the ability to
confront his accusers call witnesses on
his behalf and have a basic
understanding of the accusations against
him that would form any basis for
impeachment and calls on the House of
Representatives to provide members of
the minority that's the Republicans with
the ability to participate fully in all
proceedings and have equal authority to
issue subpoenas and other compulsory
process so those last two are important
is well Trump needs to be able to call
witnesses on his behalf and Trump needs
to have a basic understanding of the
accusations against him that were formed
that would form any basis for
impeachment let me ask you this is kind
of similar to the Syria question when
President Trump redeployed those troops
from Syria everyone had a lot of strong
opinions about it and very few people
had any knowledge about the situation so
it's the same for for impeachment on
this front close your eyes
tell me what they're trying to impeach
Trump for can you do it specifically I
know it's something with Ukraine right
specifically what are they trying to
impeach Trump for what we've heard is
they're trying to impeach Trump for a
quid pro quo with Ukrainian military aid
well what specifically what aid did he
withhold what evidence is there against
them what law did he violate now that
many Democrats are admitting that he
didn't violate any law that's why you
have pieces in USA Today saying it
doesn't matter if he didn't commit a
crime you can impeach the president for
not committing a crime which is false
and it's unconstitutional and it's very
clear from the debates that took place
at the founding of our country it's the
same thing and they're just the media
and the left but I repeat myself are
trying to run roughshod over this
process with a lot of insinuation
and not a whole lot in the way of
specifics Oh Lindsey Graham is trying to
get its specific here and he's trying to
get the Republicans to participate much
more fully in this Democrats are making
a huge mistake what is the mistake the
Democrats are starting to believe their
own press releases this is true not just
in the impeachment this is true of the
left broadly the problem with the left
right now is not that they're hurling
some unfair or opportunistic attacks
that's politics the problem is they're
starting to believe the nonsense that
they're spewing I remember this is some
of the best advice my mother ever gave
me when I was a young man I don't know I
was pretty 11 or 12 years old and I was
always very good at school you know top
of the class all this so there's a
little 11 year old Michael and I was
just getting a little full of myself my
head was getting a little too big and my
mother turned to me and said Michael
yeah you did great on that test or yeah
you got that award or whatever it's just
very important don't ever believe your
own press releases meaning it's true
that we all present an image to the
world of some kind of success or
achievement but just remember the image
you're putting out to the world is not
necessarily the reality of the situation
or it's certainly not the sum total of
the situation same thing with social
media on social media we put out a
highlight reel of our lives but that's
not the totality of our lives we also
make mistakes we also sin we also have
imperfect information we also are lazy
we also glut ourselves we also we
there's a lot more to life than this
best of real and for the Democrats if
they're going to go out there and
they're gonna say all right we caught
Trump using Joe Biden's name on a phone
call with the president of Ukraine
therefore we need to remove him from
office I think they know deep down I
think that or at least they knew that
that is not sufficient basis to to throw
a president out of office and to
overturn a presidential election but
they're they're beginning to they're
beginning to buy it they're trying to
make a meal out of a cupcake and it
doesn't look good here's another example
president Trump within just the past few
weeks
redeploys the troops out of northern
Syria the Democrats say Isis is going to
be reformed then days later President
Trump announces we've killed the head of
Isis Abu Bakr al-baghdadi totally
undercuts the democratic narrative they
Double Down they say well it doesn't
matter if you kill al Baghdadi's some
other guy is gonna take over in his
place two days later we announced we
killed the other guy we killed the guy
who is going to take over for al
Baghdady the spokesman for Isis doesn't
matter they doubled down you still have
left wingers at academic conferences and
elsewhere there was there's actually one
the other day who came out and said
president Trump has aligned the United
States and aligned himself with Isis the
inspiration of leaders who are going to
put people first is so important and
that's going to make people vote another
reason why people are gonna vote because
Donald Trump is manipulating the White
House and has aligned himself with Isis
and Saudi Arabia
I take I I have to say that that is not
true it is not true today is vote for
civility vote for president who's not
aligned himself with the most dangerous
foreign nations that are the reason why
we okay so that was the Arizona
Democratic Party Chairman felicia
rotellini obviously she's on a panel
there they're discussing foreign policy
and she had says Trump has aligned
himself with Isis how does that make
sense that makes sense in a world where
you believe all the BS that you're
spewing that does not make sense in a
world where Trump just killed Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi the head of Isis and the
next leader of Isis the spokesman prices
and took out Isis in the first place
something that Barack Obama was not able
to do it doesn't make sense in that
world and it doesn't help politicians to
just follow they're opportunistic hack
attacks forever
you've got to ballast yourself a little
bit with reality otherwise nobody is
going to believe you it's not going to
serve them very well you know Joseph
burro on MSNBC scarborough hates Trump
because Trump makes fun of him fairly
regularly and said that his girlfriend
has an ugly face and so Joe is on there
with his girlfriend on MSNBC and he was
listening to President Trump announced
the death of Abu Bakr al-baghdadi great
thing and he couldn't give it to him he
said Trump it was so awful the way he
talked about killing the worst
terrorists in the world Trump actually
he sounded like a terrorist he sounded
like Saddam Hussein the raid that killed
bin Laden was a seminal moment in the
Obama administration
how will Baghdadi's death shaped the
Trump presidency that's the question
we're looking at this that is a question
we're looking at and of course Richard
Haass the president United States went
on talking about how Baghdady died like
a quote dog a coward of whimpering
whimpering and sniffling he sounded not
like a president the United States he
actually sounded like Saddam Hussein
after torturing people
sounded like Muammar Qaddafi after he
would torture people it was again just
like the chance of lock him up last
night at the game it was steeply on
American deeply troubling so what Joe
did is the same thing the left does when
they call right-wingers Nazis they draw
a moral equivalence between opposite
things so what what Joe is saying this
is something that I've noticed left
wingers do it's a very postmodern kind
of tactic they'll say okay you've got a
terrorist who killed a lot of people and
raped killed pillaged and burned and if
you kill that terrorist you're the same
as the terrorists you're not if you kill
that terrorist you're the opposite of
the terrorist if you've got a really why
because to exact justice is not the same
thing as to inflict injustice you might
do the same act or a similar act I mean
in the case of Baghdad II that's not the
case Baghdad II was personally a rapist
a murderer an absolute monster and a dog
who
track down and eaten by dogs before he
blew his guts up all over the walls of a
cave but let's say that let's say what
we were really getting Baghdady for is
because he just killed people take all
the rape and all the the things that
make it even more vicious out of it he
just went out and killed a lot of people
and then we go in and kill him the acts
themselves look exactly the same but
they're not the same act because the
killings that Abu Bakr al-baghdadi was
committing were unjust and the killing
of Abu Bakr al Baghdadi is just the
Justice is the thing I'll give you
another example from American history
because what the left is banking on is
that you have no sense of history I mean
not forget 200 years ago or 300 years
ago
they want to hope that you have no sense
of history 50 60 years ago so they say
listen to Trump he said that Baghdady
died like a dog that makes him pretty
much the same thing as a terrorist why
because he used very evocative language
here's here's an example from the second
world war war I think we can all agree
was it a good just war the best war ever
you know we we were the good guys and
that the other guys were the baddies
during the Second World War is very
famous speech Patton's speech to the
Third Army General Patton nobody would
call him a terrorist here's just just a
little sampling of the speech he said I
don't want to get any messages saying I
am holding my position we are not
holding a GD thing I'm gonna I'm gonna
abbreviate all of the copious swear
words that Patton used because this is a
family show let the Germans do that we
are advancing constantly and we are not
interested in holding on to anything
except the enemy is go Leone you know
I'm talking about down there we are
going to twist his Colleoni and kick the
living Shi T out of him all of the time
our basic plan of operation is to
advance and to keep on advancing
regardless of whether we have to go over
under or through the enemy we are going
to go through him like crap through a
goose
like Shi T through a tinhorn we're not
going to just shoot the sons of female
dogs we're going to rip out
they're living g-d guts and use them to
grease the treads of our tanks we're
going to murder those lousy hun people
who deal with male genitalia by the
bushel effing basket war is a bloody
killing business you've got to spill
their blood or they will spill yours rip
them up the belly shoot them in the guts
when shells are hitting all around you
and you wipe the dirt off your face and
realize that instead of dirt it's the
blood and guts of what was once your
best friend besides you you'll know what
to do it's a little more evocative than
Trump saying that a terrorist died like
a dog that's a little more gruesome and
bloody are we gonna say that General
Patton is the same thing as Hitler no
General Patton is not the same thing as
his enemy because General Patton was
advocating just killings he was on the
right side of that war he was fighting
for our country which was not just in
the right because it's our country it
was morally in the right same thing here
with Trump but if Joe Scarborough were
on the air in the world the Second World
War it say oh this this General Patton
he's pretty much Hitler I mean we're
pretty much a Nazi country I mean it's
it's so it's so it sounds like the worst
person on earth no there is a difference
here there is no moral equivalence now I
don't I think if you got Joe Scarborough
out for a beer or a wine cooler or
whatever Joe Scarborough drinks if you
got him out at a bar and you said hey I
know that Trump made fun of your
girlfriend and said that she has an ugly
face
putting the personal stuff aside do you
really think that Trump is the same
thing as Saddam Hussein do you really
think there's a moral equivalence I
think he would have to admit no I don't
believe it I'm just getting a little
carried away with my rhetoric but it's
okay because my audience buys it and
I've whipped them up to a friend into a
frenzy
and so we're I'm just gonna keep it up
it's not gonna end well because the
people are a lot smarter than the left
things and the people can see a
nonsensical impeachment for face value
they can see it for what it is the
people
see the Donald Trump is not the same
thing as Saddam Hussein the people can
see this is my favorite one of the whole
day Katy Hill Katy Hills that Democratic
congressman who was caught in a throuple
with a 22 year old female staffer and
her husband taking nude photos ripping
bong hits that showed she has this weird
Nazi tattoo on her I don't even know how
to begin then she decided to not only
have this sexual relationship with a
staffer which is an ethics violation in
and of itself not just a cheat on her
husband or cheat with her husband I
guess but she then dumped the staffer
and her husband for her mail finance
director Katie Hill is pretending to be
the victim here she's pretending to be
the victim of sexual oppression and
abuse and a patriarchal society because
she dumped her female 22 year old
staffer and her husband for some other
guy on her staff she's pretending that
this now how does she get away with this
because in the me2 era we have to
believe all women infamy to era all men
bad all women good even women like Katie
Hill who were engaging in
extraordinarily inappropriate
relationships with young staffers who
work for her but in the meze banking on
this me too era widespread blanket rule
that women can do no wrong nobody really
believes that nobody believes that women
are biologically incapable of lying
nobody believes that women are
biologically incapable of exploiting
their staff members this is this is a
Katie Hill announcing her resignation as
though she were the victim I'm Katie
Hill and last night I announced the most
difficult decision of my life that I
would be resigning from Congress I made
this decision so that my supporters my
family my staff in our community will no
longer be subjected to the pain
inflicted by my abusive husband and the
brutality of hateful political
operatives this coordinated campaign
carried out by the right-wing media and
Republican opponents enabling and
perpetuating my husband's abuse by
providing him a platform
disgusting and unforgivable and they
will be held accountable but I will not
allow myself to be a distraction from
the constitutional crisis we're faced
with and the critical work of my
colleagues and so I have to take my
personal fight outside the halls of
Congress too many Americans are counting
on Washington to fulfill our promises of
quality health care housing we can
afford and a government that works for
the people and I cannot let this
horrible smear campaign get in the way
of that work to my supporters in our
district and across our great country
please know that we did something
incredible we proved that an imperfect
woman the 31 year old daughter of a
nurse and a police officer who never
planned to run for office has a place in
the people's house no she doesn't
she didn't prove that at all she's
resigning right now because of her abuse
of power and exploitation of her staff
and extraordinarily poor judgment she
proved the opposite of what she's saying
and then she brings up her husband's
abuse how did her husband abuse her has
she ever named a single actual instance
of abuse
I guess she's saying her husband abused
her by not just allowing her to leave
him consequence-free without ever ever
giving any of his side of the story for
her other staffer she didn't prove
anything she proved that she has
committed abuse abuse of power she's
abusing her power to exploit her young
female staff members she's abusing her
the per marriage bond she's abusing that
marriage now obviously that didn't mean
very much who knows for how long she's
abusing her power to do illegal drugs
actually I don't know pot now is being
legalized everywhere we'll get into the
specifics of that because it actually
ties in with this exact theme of today's
show but she abused that she's she was
found to having Nazi tattoo in the naked
photos that she unbelievably
irresponsibly allowed to be taken and
now she's pretending to be the victim
she proved that she's a derelict and
that even left wingers have some sense
of shame because they forced her to
resign
but she can't admit it because facts can
never get in the way of the narrative
that Time magazine web covering this
whole story if I were a left-winger I
would just let her go away quietly she's
obviously a kook and a lunatic get her
out of there get some blams Democrat
politician in office no big deal don't
blow it up
Time magazine can't help themselves they
can't help but believe their own press
releases they have a headline quote
Katie Hill is the first millennial
lawmaker to resign because of nudes she
won't be the last
she's not resigning cuz of news she's
resigning because she exploited a young
female staff member in a bizarre sexual
relationship and then exploited another
staff member in a relationship that's
why she's resigning
Time magazine doesn't matter facts can't
interrupt the narrative last year Hill
was one of 20 Millennials most of them
women who won seats in Congress
increasing the generations
representation six fold in one cycle and
giving voice to the second largest bloc
of eligible voters this week she
resigned after nude pictures of her
throuple relationship with a female
campaign staffer were released online
without her consent and after she came
under a house ethics investigation for
an alleged relationship with a male
legislative staffer Hill's case lands
smack in the middle of the 3-way is that
a pun you know I didn't even notice that
when I first read it Hill's case lands
snack in the middle of the three-way
intersection between tech sex and power
technology has changed sex sex has
changed power and power is newly
vulnerable two strains of disgrace that
didn't exist a decade ago hold on stop
none of that is is what's going on here
this isn't a totally arbitrary random
intersection of technology which changed
sexes and know this woman violated her
marriage bond with a young female
staffer and then left both her husband
and the staffer for another staffer
there's nothing new here there's nothing
about technology that changed that she
committed very immoral acts and
exercised extremely poor judgment and
now she's being thrown out of office for
it
I'm not judging her I'm not even
throwing stones at her I'm just saying
there's consequences to your decisions
when you sleep with your staffers while
in public office this isn't this isn't
like canceled culture even this isn't
even that tweets or photos from a decade
ago showed up and therefore what you're
doing now you have to stop doing them is
that I guess that would be an example of
technology changing the nature of sex
it's not that she has a sex scandal that
is currently going on and she got thrown
out of office for it that's the oldest
story in politics
Time magazine goes on technology
provides new and humiliating ways to
document sexual encounters and all
sexual encounters especially when they
involve a public figure are now
subjected to brutal public dissection
sex scandals have always been part of
politics that's going on since time
immemorial that's not an forget in the
founding days of our republic Alexander
Hamilton one of our founding fathers got
caught in a major sex scandal where he
was chuckling some guy and then the guy
and the wife decided to extort Hamilton
for it major sex scandal John Adams said
there weren't enough [ __ ] in
Philadelphia to contain Hamilton's
secretions very new and what are we
saying is the new technology photographs
photographs have been around for a very
long time he'll maybe the first
millennial lawmaker to have to grapple
with this particularly thorny 21st
century code of conduct but she won't be
the last
she's like Hill is a totally passive
person in this entire story she's not
she committed the acts she decided to
sleep with her staffers on the campaign
she decided to bring her husband into it
for some reason she decided to leave her
husband and the staffer she it's she
made those decisions she's not a totally
passive creature she has a moral agency
and if you took Katie Hill out for a
beer well I don't know what would happen
if you took Katie Hill out for a beer
but if you took her out for a beer and
just asked her very specifically you
said congressman Hill did you do
something wrong should you maybe not
have done that I think she would say
yeah
yeah you caught me I shouldn't have
slept with my staffers and I shouldn't
left my husband for his yeah I was my
mistake but they can't allow that
honesty to get in the way of their
narrative
that narrative is just not believable to
anybody and and the left has a choice
here they can continue to pursue their
narrative relentlessly or they can speak
to the American people they're not going
to be able to do both and this is going
to affect the presidential campaign
because the people are a lot smarter
than the left thinks we've got to get to
the dumbest article on the Internet
today I mean talk about not letting the
facts get in the way of narrative in the
New York Times they are actually making
the argument with a straight face that
an attack by Indian people on black
girls is an example of toxic whiteness
I have many Indian friends none of them
are particularly white the New York
Times must have it well the New York
Times invented those the white Hispanic
in the case of George Zimmerman and
Trayvon Martin so I guess now they've
invited the white they've invented the
white Indian we will get to that we will
also get to a lot of BS on pot and Joe
Biden being refused Communion but I have
got to say goodbye to Facebook in
YouTube head on over to daily wire.com
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you got the Matt Walsh or you get to ask
questions in the mailbag coming up
tomorrow you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom and
you get the leftist tears tumblr so
important these days as all the
narratives collapse make sure you have
your tumblr or you will drown daily wire
calm we'll be right back with a lot more
a racist attack shows how whiteness
evolves that's the headline from The New
York Times what's the story story as
police in Lawrence Township New Jersey
arrested two 17 year-olds and charged
them with a lot of harassment and
intimidation because this group urinated
on black girls and hurled racial slurs
at them this is obviously a racially
bigoted attack that was the story New
York Times or those are the facts they
got New York Times said oh great we're
gonna run a story about white supremacy
and white bigotry and toxic whiteness
and they say hold up hold up New York
Times problem is the people who did the
attack or indium they're not white
they're like very much not white New
York Times said huh okay give me a
minute let me work with this so the
mainstream media didn't cover the story
for a few days and then the New York
Times realized they said oh wait a
second an attack doesn't need to be
perpetrated by white people to be the
fault of white people whiteness is still
the problem here even if the people are
very very Brown here's the New York
Times while it's tempting to see the
reported ethnicity of the boys suspected
in the assault as complicating the story
and raising questions about whether the
assault should be thought of as racist I
looked at it through a different lens
instead of asking what the boys reported
racial identity tells us about the
nature of the attack by the way I love
they keep trying to muddy up the waters
here they say look the reported
ethnicity it's there there India okay
it's their ethnic identity it's it's not
just how they identify they are Indian
okay well it can it can someone who's
not white commits a racist act yes they
can of course they can any race can
commit a racist act the piece goes on
instead of asking what the boys reported
racial identity tells us about the
nature of the attack we should see the
boys as enacting American whiteness
through anti-black assault in a very
traditional way so they're not white but
they are enacting whiteness because
according to the New York Times any
racially motivated attack is white even
even if a black person attacks a black
person on the basis of race if that were
possible they would still be performing
a white supremacist white bigoted attack
because any attack on black people is
white somehow in the bizarre logic of
the New York Times they go on this it
gets even better race is something we
perform not just something we are in our
blood and in the color of our skin
hold up full stop races your skin color
it is it you die no this is like what
happens when people pass around the pot
they take her
they take the Katy Hill bomb and they
just go whoo you know man
what if race isn't really about our race
you know what I mean like if you really
think about it you know and you really
think no it's just your race times goes
on in the New Jersey incident the
heritage or skin color of the boys
suspected of the assault doesn't matter
what matters is that they were
participating in this pattern and thus
enacting whiteness in a very traditional
way one potent way of being American no
matter where you or your parents are
from is enacting anti blackness and
traditionally acting out anti blackness
has meant acting white Wow so the time
just gets the story completely wrong
they're very upset that the perpetrators
of this crime were not white they have
the opportunity to expand their thinking
they have the opportunity to perceive
something about the world that they
didn't perceive before they have the
opportunity just not even to cover the
story but they can't do it they can't
let the facts get in the way of their
narrative because they are actually
starting to believe their own narrative
imagine if you took those New York Times
editors out for a Zima after work you
said hey guys they're sipping on their
smirnoff ice or whatever
you say guys do you really believe that
where Indians attack black people that's
white supremacy after a couple sips
they'd probably say yeah you're right
you're right okay that's obviously
absurd so no we don't believe that but
in public they are clinging so
desperately to their own narrative
they're saying yes this no it is it is
white lalala I won't let the facts get
in my way I will believe the story that
I am pushing people no better than this
this is why the New York Times
readership is down this is why people
are making fun of the New York Times
this is why they've lost their
credibility what the left believes
ultimately is that there's really no
such thing as objective truth it's that
same cynicism that you see in Pontius
Pilate who asks what is truth it's the
same cynicism that you've seen
intersectionality there's really no such
thing as race or gender or it's all
fluid it's all intersecting identities
the only thing that is real is my
subjective perception of my own
suffering of my own oppression and if I
can convey that oppression that is the
actual power and core of my identity
that is the only reality so all that
matters is the narrative that I spin
it's it's the same thing in 1984 by
George Orwell it's the same thing as big
brother if big brother tells you that
two plus two equals five you have to
believe it if big brother tells you the
two plus two equals five and two plus
two really does equal five
and you have to not just say that you
have to believe it they've they've
worked themselves up into this belief
but it isn't true
there is objective reality two plus two
does not equal five two plus two equals
four the American people know this I
think I think I think that's what
explains the 2016 election the fact that
you had this very flawed candidate and
Donald Trump you had the entire media
political establishment really on the
left and the right push
for Hillary Clinton and still and still
they picked Trump because they just knew
something was wrong with Hillary they
just didn't want to be lied to they just
it's this James Burnham's major law he
had the political philosopher Jameis
Burnham had these ten laws one of which
is everybody knows everything people are
a lot smarter than we give them credit
for you know I'm always wary of
proclamations where we say the American
people believe x y&z the American people
believe everything that I want them to
believe the American people bleh look
I'm not saying that I'm the spokesman
for the American people here however I
think that the American people can see
reality most of the time I think they're
a lot smarter than politicians and media
elites believe that they are I think
they see through this they see that
Katie Hill is not a victim she's the
perpetrator they see that Indians
attacking black people is not white
supremacy they see that an impeachment
inquiry in search of a crime is not a
legitimate impeachment they just see
that even if they don't know all the
details exactly same thing on this is
obviously a slightly less relevant to
these intense political fights but it's
the same sort of thing with the
legalization of marijuana people ask me
this sometimes when I'm at on the road
Michael what do you think about the
legalization of pot I don't like it why
don't I like it because not because I've
never smoked pot I've smoked pot number
times never cared for it as much as
stogies and a good drink but the main
reason that I opposed the legalization
of pot is because of the people who are
clamoring for it the people who are
clamoring to legalize marijuana they're
just so annoying about it that I don't
want to give it to them and one of the
things they do is they say you know
actually marijuana is like really good
for you actually it solves like every
problem if you're depressed or anxious
or or if you are like have anything
that's wrong in your life at all pot
will solve it in the CBD oil you can
just you just basically take a bath and
that and all your troubles melt away and
that just isn't true there's a yeah
there's a new study out that actually
debunks pretty much all of that
it shows that the use of cannabis THC
the active agent in marijuana the use of
that to treat people with depression
anxiety psychosis other health issues
can't be justified because there's no
evidence that they work there's no
evidence that they're safe actually this
new study which was published in the
journal Lancet psychiatry concludes that
the risks very likely outweigh the
benefits that actually it shows that
there's very low-quality evidence the
THC helps these problems and there's a
fair bit of evidence that it actually
makes the problems worse anxiety
depression and psychosis and having been
friends with a lot of pot heads over the
years I can say first and I've sort of
seen that happen so not for everybody
but a lot of the time it's all that
narrative that what when people are have
a real interest in pushing a narrative
they're much more likely to ignore
relevant facts okay this is true of
everybody but the left is taking that
right now to a radical extreme to an
absolutely outrageous extreme and those
of us who are not there those of us who
are not puffing on the Katy Hill guns
you know we're not smoking that Haitian
oregano like like the soon-to-be former
congressman we're not believing our own
press releases those of us who say we
just have a little bit more clarity and
I think it's why the left is so
screechie it's why they're so screaming
it's why they're so emotional right now
is because the reality of what's going
on in politics and culture is colliding
with their narrative and they're
realizing that those two things reality
and their storyline are not very well
connected and they are having a
breakdown because of it same thing this
act just happened to Joe Biden heaven to
Joe Biden he's on the campaign trail in
South Carolina Biden says he's a
practicing Catholic and yet Biden
supports abortion pretty radical
abortion support to now he's saying he
supports forcing people to pay for
abortions within the Catholic Church
there's a lot of disagreement on public
policy issues Adams this is mostly
tolerated
abortion is sort of where the rubber
meets the road because in abortion
you're just killing babies and the
Catholic Church cannot support the
killing of babies so it has been the
position of the Catholic Church that
Church is within its rights to withhold
Communion or to excommunicate you to
keep you out of communion with the
church to withhold the body of Christ
and live in the Blessed Sacrament but so
many priests and bishops are wishy washy
on this they don't want to do it they
want to be seen as cool they want to be
liked by politicians they're afraid that
politicians are going to attack them if
they do it so they'll allow people who
openly advocate killing babies they'll
allow them to receive the Eucharist this
began with christen and Andrew Cuomo's
father Mario Cuomo when he was governor
of New York he pioneered the Catholic
leftist live which is look I oppose
abortion personally but I support the
right of people to have them it's like
saying I oppose murder personally but I
don't think we should have laws against
murder for some reason can't quite
explain why and it was this wishy-washy
way of having both sides of the issue
and getting out of a tight spot this
priest in South Carolina denied Joe
Biden the Eucharist he was almost
certainly referring to canon 9:15 of the
canon law which says those who have been
excommunicated or interdite 'add after
the imposition or declaration of the
penalty and others obstinately
persevering in manifest grave sin are
not to be admitted to Holy Communion
this was the right thing to do one of
the reasons it's the right thing to do
the most important reason from the
pastoral point of view of the priest is
to save Joe Biden's soul Joe Biden needs
to be aware of the grave sin of
supporting infanticide that is a grave
matter that imperils his eternal soul
and will have him roasting down below or
greatly increase the chances that he's
roasting down below if he doesn't
correct his ways
that's the rehabilitative that's the
medicinal effect of withholding the
Eucharist is to clarify the reality to
take away that leftist narrative and
just give Joe Biden a little dose of
reality
you're not supposed to receive the
Eucharist if you have
in a grave mortal sin without going to
confession so you'll see very often in
Catholic churches people just stay in
the pews if they haven't gone to
confession Joe Biden out there refusing
to acknowledge the reality of that sin
it's the same situation here Joe Biden I
think after decades and decades of
Democrats pushing this line then look I
oppose abortion but I also support
abortion that that could somehow be okay
that that in any world makes sense we're
now seeing the collision of that
narrative and that reality some people
who are a little more wishy-washy and
squishy think that we should downplay
those differences between reality and
leftist narrative that somehow that will
bring them back it won't
we need a choice not an echo we need to
draw a stark distinction when we're
debating the left we don't need to be
cruel we don't need to be mean we
shouldn't do any of those things but we
should make clear the stark differences
to wake them out of a stupor a stupor
that is then brought on by arrogance and
pride and cynicism and dishonesty for
decades and decades the stupor that
causes them to believe their own press
releases we need to shake them a little
bit and we need to tell them the truth
that's our show on Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Dahl show get your
mailbag questions in see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20:19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]